yeah
I forgot to put my clock back
that's my excuse
or it's wishful thinking
right good evening to everybody
um welcome to this meeting November
meeting of the scrutiny committee
um and
um are we ready to stream live or I
guess we'll live now
yeah the um right yeah so we we are
streamed live so
um you know
um make sure that uh you know you
conduct yourselves in the in the right
way
um I'm sure you will we always do so
um if we move on to the
agenda attendances do we have any
apologies Alex
is have been received from Council hurt
Western but that's all yeah
item two are the minutes
um which were to follow
um and I hope everybody's had a chance
to read them
and can we move them at a correct record
yeah just just a few things arising from
the last meeting
um at the last meeting regarding the
Travelers I requested costs for the
current provision and information about
how we're moving them on
um I just wanted to check this
information will be included in the
December report and this will be gut
come before scrutiny because I'm not
clear and the other issue was that I
know that information was asked about
the cost of the Carrington relief Road
um but we haven't received those so I
wondered if a game we could have an
update on that and the other thing is I
know that the Old Trafford task and
finish quick wasn't isn't included on
this agenda I wondered what was
happening with that
yeah I mean that I think it's mentioned
on the last date um
um
where where
uh the the committee work program that's
so I think we'll have an update there
right
um yeah calcified win Stanley uh thank
you chair similar points I wasn't here
at the last meeting
um so it's possible it was missed out of
the minutes but the section on uh
disability access
um the two two points were answered in
the report again went offices last time
there was a third Point around the
public sector equality Duty which is not
included in here but again we can pick
it up as part of the uh the forward work
at the committee at the at the end of
the meeting thank you chair yeah okay
right
so
clearly
um there are some issues that need to be
addressed uh in in relation to The
Travelers we were promised a report from
the executive
um by the end of this
um this year so that should be in
December
um so I don't know whether that could be
forwarded to us
yeah a chair if it is this um a report I
think stand a report is scheduled to go
to the December executive on that
subject so
um the comments at councilor Oxford I'm
sure will be incorporated within that
yeah okay
right so can we agree those minutes
yeah
okay thank you
um item three is Declaration of interest
if any members have got an interest in
any item of the agenda can you
um speak now really
no
okay item four is questioned from the
public I haven't had any and so we can
move straight on to item five uh which
is the draft draft budget proposals and
we've got councilor Tom Ross and Graham
Bentley here
um to help to go through those proposals
so you've all had the
um the the slides that
um
we were circulated it with the agenda so
thanks very much Tom if you could start
thank you chair
um with permission I wasn't going to
speak to every slide because I'm
presuming that everyone's had a chance
to to read and you will have more
opportunities for questions with that
approach so um I just wanted to give a
quick summary of the um the slide deck
before we um we are happy to take any
questions or or queries from from
colleagues on the committee and first
thing to note we've got our annual um
wrong year at the start of the uh the
presentation so those uh eagle-eyed will
see that it says 2223 it should actually
read 23 24. I recall we did that last
year as well so we'll probably keep that
tradition up in future years too
um but I'll just moving pretty swiftly
on I'll go on to the um the parts that
this presentation covers so the first
part of the presentation covers the
journey from our gross budget gap which
we have estimated as 25.8 million to the
revised budget gap of 8.5 million at
October 22. we also include in this
first section expenditure pressures and
income and our assumptions in general
the next section of the presentation
lists our savings and income proposals
as it's October and they cover each
directorate each directorate being
separated out in the report the final
section highlights other areas under
consideration and also our next steps as
we continue the journey from draft stage
to final budget stage in February and
yeah scream and I are happy to take any
questions thank you
um yeah I've got I've got a few I don't
know whether you want them all at once
um just want to say thank you for the
hard work on this and it's it's really
sad that we're forced to look for cuts
like this
um and this kind of little Middle School
saves we can make rather than taking
time to do the things we really could be
doing I've got a few questions first
about car parking charges because they
don't seem to be included and I just
wanted to
I wonder what was happening with that
where there'll be a review of that and
personally I think there's no problem in
increasing car parking charges in the
attempt to get people to travel by car
less and to shop more locally
um there's also some an issue about
whether car parking fines could be means
tested as a way of getting some Revenue
um about the street lighting
um obviously they're going to be
concerns about safety so I just wanted
to have some reassurance that those
safety issues would be looked at because
I agree that it absolutely should be
done
um with EV charging points I wanted to
find out how much revenue we're getting
from them and is it something that's
going to be increased on a larger scale
and understand there will be competition
for the private sector and I wondered
how quickly would we were doing that
and the other thing was about the music
service which
um
is a very valuable service and I just
wondered how that works with I know it
says there that you're removing the
subsidy but expanding the service I just
wondered how that that worked thank you
right so no thank you very much for
those questions uh councilor Oxford I
will attempt to answer some now some
will come up in more depth at the future
sessions that you'll have over the
course of the the next few weeks
um that set out different directorates
um evening by evening but I will I will
have a go at the initial responses and
I'm sure Graeme will be very happy to
chip in with anything that's either I've
omitted so in terms of the car parking
charges uh they they will be under
review and there'll be a fees and
charges list when we get to
um when we get to the budget itself but
if scrutiny wishes to feed in and raise
um you know what you have to say about
the uh the car parking charges obviously
we can look at that report if that's
something that you wish to include in
there as we move towards the uh the
budget means testing of parking fines is
uh is quite a an interesting concept I'm
not too sure
if it would work in if how practical it
would be to to implement but I am sure
that some work can go into that to see
if it is a flyer or something that just
it would cost more to to do than than it
would uh that it would uh
generate in terms of uh income
absolutely on the street lighting I know
that this was raised by uh I think it
was Council Jerome actually at the uh
the budget exec and when we published
the papers a couple of weeks ago this
will go through a consultation
um period the the street lighting so we
want to make sure that people are
confident
um about the changes that were being
proposed and that will go through
consultation and obviously we'll look at
the feedback from the consultation as
part of that we will engage with whoever
the whoever groups individuals wish to
to be involved in that process
um EV charging points I think that's
something we'll probably have to come
back to you with with more detail unless
Graham has something to say
um but again that that's There's an
opportunity to explore that further in
the um in the sessions that you've got
coming up music service you'll be aware
is very close to my heart
um I know that we're looking at a phased
reduction of the subsidy but I have to
say I'm delighted to say that the music
service at the moment is facing a very
high demand and probably the the
challenge we have is is capacity and
being able to meet that demand and I
think though that is a logistical um
issue it is quite a nice challenge to
have you know the music service is very
strong we've got a great set of people
in that organization a great leader of
that organization and our current
challenge is to make sure that we can
get as many young people accessing that
service as possible so hopefully that's
some answers I don't know if Graham has
anything else to say
thank you
thank you chair can I Echo the first two
points made by uh councilor Oxford an
amazing piece of work to what
uh thank you Council Ross just a comment
briefly with regards to parking charges
obviously I think in trafford's local
Villages sometimes putting that in just
encourages older folk and those with
disabilities to just drive further to
free supermarkets so it's a bit of a
false economy with regards to business
rates because you just punished the
local shops that are obviously already
struggling in the current climate but in
terms of a question I would like to have
a response from you on on where we're up
to with our lobbying program because
obviously I think that's
um a really good idea hugely important
and I'd like to know what sort of
response we've had from our altering on
sale West MP in particular thank you
thank you very much uh Council for us on
the first point about the packages
obviously that's something that you as a
scrutiny group may wish to talk about
and feed into the process with um I'm
sure you'll come to a a view
collectively around that area in terms
of the lobbying you you may have seen
that um the leader of the council Andrew
Weston has written
um about the financial challenges we
face I know and if I may I think that
Council West may know more about
um the engagement with um with the mp42
and say West Gray and Brady about the um
about the um the lobbying process but we
know that we have approached local MPS
we're working with wider stakeholders as
well
um across the um across different bodies
and organizations and we're also looking
at a um making
our challenge was set telling the story
of our budget pressures in a most
plain and understandable way as possible
so that people unlike me who eat sleep
and breathe local government Finance may
may be a bit clearer in terms of of what
we have in terms of facing um was this a
challenge year on year
um but I don't know in terms of the um
in terms of the MP gray and Brady side
of things it might be when Council work
and has to say you might be able to give
us a look on that you may not but thank
you for your question
okay
okay
sorry could I just just add to that last
answer I think the the role of the F20
group
um
it's not been as vociferous as it was
last year started last year so the piece
of work and the evidence base was
developed last year we lobbied
government
we have had a dialogue it was
leicestershire County Council who headed
that up last year we've we've we've been
in communication with them and they have
lobbied the Secretary of Secretary of
State in the last couple of weeks
um who I know has been discussing with
the local government Association as well
around the plight that local
government's got at the moment so
we'll wait and see what whether that
falls on deaf ears but the soundings
have gone out as part of that
okay
Council of wind Stanley thank you chair
uh at the risk of repetition
um to Echo what counteracts with said
it's an amazing piece of work listen to
um
present was a hugely complicated area in
such a
a small number of very very clear slides
and I'm also horrified that after 12
years austerity we've got to look for
even more savings when will this end
um but some uh specific questions one is
just to confirm my reading of this
largest correct that the proposed
Savings of
11.3 million already baked into the
forecast so we have to deliver those to
get to the eight and a half million and
remaining eight and a half million gap
oh good lord
um
and one of the points about uh the way
forward was that there's potential and
change in staff terms and conditions
um I have a horrible feeling that covers
a multitude of sins and I was wondering
if they would get any detail about the
um the kind of discussion that's the
kind of change in terms of conditions
you were looking at uh thank you Chuck
okay thank you very much councilor
windstandy um yes you're right the the
huge amount of savings and uh income
proposals that have been put together
that's come from a series of workshops
over the the summer they are already
baked into this budget proposal and we
do indeed have a forecast 8.5 million
pound Gap that we have to bridge
um in terms of positives on that there
are things that will come into play
between now and the end of the year
um one of which will be the settlement
at the end of the year and
though I can't we don't know what the
government will do but hopefully that
may assist us the other one will all
eyes will be on the nine sorry the 17th
of November for the statement
um that the chancellor makes next week
there's lots of speculation going around
about that at the moment things change
from day to day as to what the
governments are targeting that will give
us some clarity around around the um to
the challenge that we uh that continue
to face and last week
um I chaired our most recent finance and
change board which if you P colleagues
were here at the last exclusion we went
through the financing change so I
chaired a meeting of that last week and
there's a number of things that are
still under consideration as we look to
bridge the gap between now and the end
of the year in terms of stuff terms and
conditions again I think it was
councilor Blackburn who who raised this
with me at the exec meeting a couple of
weeks ago and at the moment our focus is
on the vacancy management side and that
is where I want our Focus to remain if
that change is we will of course be in
consultation with the trade unions and
staff groups but at this point in time
the the assumption that we're making is
to look at the vacancy management side
look at how that we can achieve savings
that way
and hopefully that'll be a limit on what
we do but of course if that changes we
will be in full consultation with our
trade unions and also the staff groups
that we have in the borough
okay
Council of Prophecy
thank you chair
um
yeah it's really a difficult budget but
I think it's it's been prevented
presented very well it's easy to
understand I think it gives us a clear
understanding of where we're up to so I
think that's really welcomed we are at a
point no way it's it's becoming
increasingly difficult not to have an
impact on Service delivery because of
you know the the reductions that we're
gonna have to make
um my question really focused on the
there's a series of eight potential
reviews going forward
um obviously a lot of work there
um to do to do or I'll go through all
that are there any of those particularly
which you might want to prioritize
or what they're all going to run
concurrently to try and
make the potential savings the one that
I would potentially look at would be the
enforcement activity potentially you
know you could re
have a double benefit in terms of
reducing congestion and bringing an
extra income I know it's not quite that
simple but that's the thinking so I just
wondered if what other priorities are
the reviews
thank you uh councilor Proctor and thank
you very much everyone say on a general
Point thank you very much for the
positive feedback in terms of the
presentation of the um the slides today
that is all down to Graham and his team
of people around him who managed to make
finance a lot more accessible than it
than it could be so you know it is
appreciated this good feedback
in in terms of the the other areas to be
considered I'm confident that we can
look at all of those areas um this has
been part of the finance and change
process that we started immediately
after the budget in in February so
there's various things that we're
working on concurrently between now and
the end of the year and we have to we
have to because of the challenges we
face in terms of your specific about the
um the traffic enforcement and I must be
clear that's not looking at a congestion
charge at all that is looking at the
behavior of cars and possible cameras
there is going to be a paper
um due at executive in the next few
weeks I think it is which we'll be
looking at that and it's similar work to
stuff that's been covered I think it's
old and Council that's been looking at
particular Junctions and and how to use
enforcement cameras to tackle bad
driving in that way and to ease
congestion flow that way but I must
stress that any money that was generated
from that would have to go to specific
things like active travel and other
things in that area can't go into the
General Revenue budget so we'd have to
look at using that money carefully we
just got to work it through and make
sure it's something that is is
worthwhile doing
counselor Carter
thank you and again extend thanks to
Graham and the team and yourself
[Music]
um councilor Ross a couple of questions
unless I'm misreading it this is saying
that if all of those identified
potential savings are realized on time
effectively there's still an eight and a
half million pound budget Gap and at the
end of the document this scope for other
areas for consideration what confidence
is there that
the other areas for consideration can
materialize in an enormous
saving of eight and a half million
pounds question one and question two
looking at the
very helpful long list of hairs areas
that have been considered one of the new
ones I'm always attracted by the um the
largest numbers in the council wide
budget
there's realignment of Treasury
management budget
which I confess sounds very very
exciting but more exactly still it saves
3.8 million pounds
so could you explain what realignment of
Treasury management budget means
pleasing and how does it
generate such an astonishing difference
thank you
certainly in terms of your first
question I'm confident there'll be
significant income and Savings in those
areas that we're considering we just
haven't had the opportunity yet to put
hard figures on them they weren't ready
in time for um for the draft budget
stage I can't say it will Bridge
everything but it will certainly help
make that that Gap smaller and then
obviously we'll explore other areas
until we get to that balanced part you
know balanced stage at the um the budget
in in February in terms of the
realignment of the treasury management
budget there's two sides to that the
first one is the increase in interest
rates that's been happening recently and
you may have seen from the current
Revenue budget monitor reports that
we've had a unintended
unanticipated increase in Investments
income on our cash balances because the
interest rates has gone up and that's
following a an upwards Trend at the
moment obviously we can have a
discussion about the pros and cons of uh
of interest rates and the impact that
that has on on many many people but from
a council perspective at this point in
time the interest that we're getting is
increasing and that is helping support
our budget and will help support the
future budget the other element of the
the treasury budget management is
looking at realigning our um bad debt
provision but we would only look at that
if we had assurances that was a robust
thing to do so I'm sure that Graham
would be happy to jump in at this stage
to add anything that I've missed
yeah thanks Tom I think
there's a number of areas that we're
looking at I think the last one that Tom
referred to which which is around what
we call our our minimum Revenue
provision what we set aside to repay
debt
government in effect determine the
approach as an authority can take each
of those approaches must be prudent so
they're quite restrictive but we do have
some flexibility that we're considering
in in discussion with our external
Auditors about an approach on that they
are big numbers because when you think
the level of debt the council's got
which is probably and I I guess at this
point in excess of 300 million
so they they are notably big numbers
um
I think
obviously made reference to the rises in
interest rates which is quite Stark in
terms of what we're getting and the
in-year budget monitoring position at
period fourth there was benefit to the
budget position because the rate
increases then but we know what's
happened since base rates have jumped
again so they've been more money coming
back into that Revenue to support
thankfully a little bit the India budget
monitoring position I think the other
consideration we've got at the moment is
what we do in terms of our councils
pension contributions to the greater
Manchester pension fund so each year we
pay pension contributions of about 14 or
15 million pounds
what we've done in the last couple of
what what we get at every three years we
get told what our pension contribution
rate is for
our employees
we pay that certain moment it's 20 but
what we've been doing is making an
advanced payment that covers the next
three years and we're in a position now
of having to decide do we want to make
an advance payment from April 23
or are we better given where we are with
interest rates actually investing that
ourselves so a combination of those
factors is why this number is quite a
big big figure so it's just obviously
better to do that than impact on
services
thank you
okay
councilor wetton
thank you
um I've got a couple of questions but
I'll first of all respond to the point
on representations
um
the the letter that uh the leader of the
council sent to government was was
copied to Sir Graham Brady
um unaware of that I wrote To Sir Grant
Brady
um and I stressed trafford's
um not that he needed to a history
lesson I stressed trafford's history of
poor settlements
um I
um outlined the
um the cross-party F20 campaign and
um I provided a lot of details on the
current budget dilemma
um
I I had a reply from Instagram
to say which said that he had heard from
the leader of the council and that he
has written to the minister in support
of trafford's case
um
I think that's the current minister
from the check the date I think it's the
current minister so but no doubt that it
would be the letter would be forwarded
if it wasn't
um that's just a little joke
um
so
um certainly I followed up on what we
were asked to do and uh sir Graham uh
has followed up on on what we're asked
to do so the case is
um I mean he has got
as as we all know now excellent contacts
in government
um so I he knows the right people to
speak to if anything can be done I'm
sure it it will be done
in terms of my questions there's one I
have which
um I'm several years late in asking so
do forgive me
um but the one percent uh adult social
care
um
that
um is being included in this budget is
something that uh over the last several
years is something that is
um an item of the increase in council
tax is that a
cumulative process so our all those
years of one percent
um
reserved for adult social care or are
they just at the year after absorbed
into the general budget and a new and a
new one percent applied I don't know if
I've made my question clear there but so
that's that point and I just wanted to
check on on one of these slides that you
talk about funding examples and in
business rates you refer to
um
indexation of the multiplier and a
benefit of
six million pounds and I just
wanted to understand a bit more about
that indexation it presumably that's
um one of the
um
sort of inflation rates that are used
for such calculations
um
um if so what sort of figure are we
talking about and is there a concern
about actually the impact on business
rate payers particularly smes who are
having such a well many of them will be
having such a difficult time at the
moment
so I hope that those were clearly enough
questions for you to have a go and reply
to me thank you thank you very much
councilor first of all thank you for
getting in touch with uh with with gray
and Brady and for doing what you have
done there that is really appreciated at
a time like this where budgets are under
such pressure we need every voice
possible to to make the case for for
better funding so thank you for that I
understood your question about adult
social care but I'm going to get grown
to clarify the the answer and likewise
the indexation I think is probably
better to hear from Graham on that side
of things so thank you
yeah thanks to me for
asking Instagram as well I think every
every voice helps um I think just in
terms of the social care precept
we've been allowed by government to Levy
that for probably the last three or four
years
um and it in in part offsets the annual
increases in our social care
budget so it doesn't fully meet it
it's in but it helps contribute towards
those Rising costs in adult social care
so we if if we use the example if our
Bandy council tax was a thousand pound
and the adult social care precept was
one percent we would put that onto the
thousand pound that's then baked in
the following year
base has been increased the previous
year so that's always in so it's a
cumulative benefit that you've got from
the adult social care precepts because
we've got a cumulative cost pressure
because that cost pressure has never
gone away as well so
it it just racks up I could what I can
do is I can give you a breakdown of the
preset allowances that we've been
allowed to raise over the last few years
if that helps and you can see how much
council tax we're raising through bandi
on from the precepts might be quite
interesting to see that so we can do
that I think
in terms of the business rates
um just to explain the multiplier the
multiplier is one aspect of that figure
we've put on there of six million so
in any normal year
a business would have to pay its
business rates based on
the rateable value of its property Times
by the business rates multiplier
accommodation of the two gives them the
annual rates bill each and every year
the government increased the multiplier
and that's increased by RPI
based on what it's what RPA is in
September
so this year
of the bills for next year should in
theory the multiplier should go up by
about 10 percent
so what government's done in the last
few years they have restricted the
multiplier increase
to something less than RPI
to protect businesses
but in doing that that affects our
business rates income
so what they've done is compensate us
for the difference that's how it works
through the system so what we're
anticipating is an element of
compensation from government because we
expect them to restrict the business
rates multiplier and not pass on a 10
increase to business
um other aspects of business rates that
we've looked at as part of this budget
process is
the business rate appeals provision that
we hold and we hold that in case we get
appeals against business rate bills
um so we've taken a view as to what we
can what we
think we can release from that provision
um but
I think it's just one of these things
about volatility of the budget we're
quite reliant on business rate income
but there's a lot of volatility so that
volatility in the main comes from a lot
of it's the Trafford Center
and we've seen that this year that
um
we have seen reductions in our business
rate tax base because shops in the
Trafford Center of course for
refurbishments so we see a drop it will
come back on stream so we have to manage
that through so a combination of things
within the 6 million but it's mainly
appeals provision and some indexation
benefits because we think the government
will cap it and compensate us
I thought about my sense if we might
just come back on that particular point
then are you confident that the
government level of compensation will
will be around 10 10 I.E around the
inflation the September inflation rate
we've not budgeted for 10 compensation
nowhere near that because we think that
we're trying to restrict the amount of
compensation they give us so we've set
it at about five percent right okay yeah
and it's only on a proportion of our
business rates so it's not on
um on everything but again
as GM treasurers we've discussed that
position
um and we think we've set a prudent
level of compensation at about five
percent rather than the ten percent
which what I don't think will happen
yeah
yeah
[Music]
thanks uh councilor wetton and thanks
for writing to Graham braiding as he say
he has been very busy
um and uh
and Andy does have contact with the
people in high places there it's usually
to sack them really not and that's
probably not much used to us
foreign
councilor Thompson
it's uh just I want some clarification
really going back to the treasury
management budget and the 3.8 million in
savings and that's going to come from
the increasing interest rates in our
investments so that's from the capital
spend the capital income is it not I'm
just wondering
can we spend that on on Frontline
services or is it is that one of those
protected funds that we can't spend on
on our services so just want some
clarification around that that makes
sense
yeah good question I think
treasury management function is is
purely the investing of our Surplus cash
on a day-to-day basis so we're not we're
not borrowing money and it's not through
the our asset investment strategy it is
simply the investment of our Surplus
cash that we have on a day-to-day basis
we we manage the cash flow to make sure
we can afford the revenue budget and the
day-to-day commitments cover payroll
when it falls due
um we obviously get receipts of council
tax on the first of the month so we're
managing that and we're investing cash
when we don't need it up to points when
we do so it's purely from the treasury
management function
so we're not borrowing money to invest
at all through the asset strategy that's
that's totally separate function
I think on a wider point
although it doesn't sound a treasury
management strategy is actually quite
interesting when you get underneath the
um the Bonnet of it all so if there's um
if there's an opportunity for I know
it's dealt with via accounts and audit
and it comes to cancel the uh the
midpoint and the end of year report but
it's always worth bringing someone down
from treasury management to explain the
functions X it is actually quite
fascinating what they do on a daily
basis and the amounts that they
contribute towards this budget at times
thank you councilor Coggins
thank you um and uh thanks for all the
the infern reports guys um I had a few
questions about
um the asset investment strategy so the
reduction of 1.5 million I think
um I was wondering sometimes that is
down as a reduction just because we
intend to spend it we haven't found a
thing to spend it on
um and I didn't know if that was why
it's down there or if this is an
intention to reduce the funds put into
that or if we were ready to spend it but
haven't been able to find anything good
to spend it on so that was the first one
um and
um I also wanted to ask obviously we
were very clear that there wouldn't be a
congestion charge well we could have a
congestion charge if we want to raise
some more money and reduce congestion
um or we could have a workplace parking
Levy as works well in Nottingham and
they're one of the only cities in the UK
I think that has reduced the amount of
um unnecessary traffic going
International Society is thriving and so
there are obviously some ways which we
can raise money that would solve some of
our other problems and I'm wondering if
those are up for consideration thank you
thank you very much the um the invest
asset investment strategy the reduction
of 1.5 million I think it's because in
the last couple of years as you may have
seen from our out turn report on our
monitoring report we're not achieving
the um the income that we originally in
budget to so we are we are getting
Revenue in from it and it is a crucial
bit of our budget that's
um supporting Frontline services but the
budget aim that the Target that we have
we've not reached it the past couple of
years so we've just taken that decision
well let's reduce that Target because
let's be realistic with the numbers that
we put together in this um in in this
draft budget
um in terms of the um in terms of the
the charging work place uh
um charges there's certainly things that
we can look to explore um I know that we
always look to best practices and other
examples in other areas particularly
around reducing carbon impact but if
there's a way of also adding in support
to the council we are happy to explore
it will go through the process us we'll
look at you know paper consultation but
yeah no our eyes and ears are open to
that sort of suggestion
are there any other questions
yeah
um
I think
um we we are going to
look at the newsletter budgets and and
the children's services and
um uh and and the Adult Services
within our scrutiny program that we've
got for for the budget and we'll be
inviting them to to you know the uh the
chief and second time and and I think
I mean you can explain if you want but I
think if it is probably better if it's
explained by the director yeah so what
what I would say is that that councilor
Hines will be far more eloquent at
explaining that than I ever could be so
I know you've got sessions coming up and
that's where you'll all have the
opportunities to really dig deep into
the um into the savings and income
proposals we have but yeah I'm sure
Council Hines will be very happy to go
into greater detail at that specific uh
meeting
yeah
okay it is no no other questions can I
just uh thank you for the the
presentation and and the answering of
the questions I think the format is
really good
um clearly we we do have two budget
meetings uh one on the 29th and the one
on the first of December
um and the first one will be
uh around the budget because obviously
there's a lot of other things
um that that are in the draft budget uh
particularly around
um you know the reserves the amount
reserves and all of that which is not
included in in this but I think what's
included in this uh are the savings that
we've having to make and the outline of
the uh of the budget and I think that's
really helpful for us to get our heads
around around that
um and and on that first meeting on the
29th as well as you know looking more
deeply into
um the the draft budget and the reserves
and so on
um we will be looking at the place
directorate
um and the savings that they make and
then the second meeting will be about
the knees LED budgets really and we will
be touching on the issues that you've
raised uh Lawrence so
um yeah okay well
[Music]
yeah I just don't want
um from the last time the budget came uh
it was saying that um those requests
requests that all the discretionary
services to be listed within the budget
scrutiny process
I thank you chair thank you very much
for that reminder yes that is still
going to happen at some point we just
haven't got those figures together in
time and they just need a quick review
um but it is still our full intention to
to get that information to you we just
couldn't do it this time yeah that's
fair enough
okay then well thanks very much uh for
coming along tonight as as always uh we
appreciate your your time and all the
work that uh you're obviously still
doing around the budget because uh it's
not completed as yet so we still don't
know what the government grants going to
to to to look like and there's a lot of
other factors that we we know at this
um you know with the cost of living
crisis and and so on it is very
difficult budget to to set
um but I think you've made a strong
start in terms of of that and uh
and we'll look forward to
um you know the other session so that we
have so thanks very much
so we'll now move on to item six the
climate change action plan performance
Aiden
thank you chair and just before I speak
to this item if you'll uh indulge me I
did want to just supplement counselor
lost his response to councilor Coggins
on um the way that's been undertaken in
Nottingham
um just to assure you there has been an
initial conversation it's in its
absolute infancy
um but it is on our radar
um so I suppose be very willing to have
a conversation with you
um about that and keep you included in
that book as it progresses I think what
they've done in Nottingham if I've
understood it correctly is interesting
um as essentially I think it's pretty
much funded to the Metrolink service
well they're equivalent their tram
service in Nottingham so
um certainly I struggled when I tried to
get my head around it to understand why
more local authorities haven't looked at
that sort of model so um I hope that
gives you some Assurance anyway that um
it is on the radar but the conversations
have been very much in their infancy
thank you and anyway thank you chairman
thank you for also for the opportunity
to come and speak with scrutiny
committee and to discuss with members
the work that is being undertaken within
the climate change and transport
strategy portfolio and I'm not going to
speak at length um to the report which
provides an overview of the work around
the carbon neutral action plan however
you will see the section two of the
report outlines work that has already
been completed with Section 3 placing
those achieved pieces of work within a
wider context of other ongoing projects
in the action plan the tables in Section
3 aim to provide an open and honest
assessment of some of the work that is
behind Target or some of the work that
is considered at risk similarly section
4 the report provides a Frank commentary
on the challenges faced in striving to
fully realize the aims of the action
plan explaining why some areas of work
are recognized as being behind or at
risk
and further data in respective
monitoring carbon emissions is provided
in Section 5 of the report
um
sorry I'm confusing my notes
um
so in providing a very simple summary of
what the report aims to explain I think
the report essentially demonstrates that
much of the low-hanging fruit on the
action plan has been delivered but
they're achieving
um
the the bigger projects that are
outlined in the plan that that presents
far more challenge
um I think the from a common sense
perspective this that shouldn't really
be a surprise to any of us and so with
that show I hope that provides um some
of the summary of uh the report on the
width's been undertaken to date and the
work that remains to be pursued uh and
with that I'm pleased that the council's
director of regulatory services and also
the council's principal sustainability
and climate change officer have also
attended committee this evening
um I absolutely prepared to seize the
floor to them now if there's anything
that they would like to add but
otherwise I'm sure that they are as I am
more than happy to answer any questions
or reflect on any comments the committee
members may have this evening thank you
chair
uh
yes yes thank you thank you chair
um and good evening councilors um yeah I
think as Council Williams has outlined
um I think where we are with this is
that um clearly we've come from a low
base we've we've moved as the as the
first section of the report shows you
know the broad range of activity but
we're now at that stage
um of that the harder ground to be
perfectly honest where actually more
effort is required in order to to show
dividends
um and I think that's what we we've
endeavored to do within section four of
the report is is sort of you know be up
be open about there are some things here
that are are quite hard and you know we
shouldn't be too surprised about that
because we're sitting here in um you
know the world's first industrial uh
City uh and of course that City in that
industrialization is predicated on on
carbon consumption to a large degree and
so we have to re-engineer the way we
operate as as a as a society and as a
city region to mitigate the impacts of
climate change so you know highly
surprising there's some some fairly
tough work in all of this but I think
perhaps just to categorize where there
are those challenges and I think if you
look at section four
um I think broadly there are in three
areas really
um they're aware we've got certain
external factors that perhaps mean that
where we're intending to do things
um uh we're dependent on on third
parties or other processes and they've
not either been able to progress or work
quite in the way that we anticipated so
we could look at say the local plan
which is having to follow places for
everyone and all Low Places for everyone
is now at the examination and and doing
well you know it's still got some way to
go so accordingly the local plan will
will have to follow in its wake
um
equally
um you know there's quite a few
um where work is ongoing workers
commence but there's still
um some way to to go and it needs um you
know we've we've got to work with our
partners um to complete that so things
like green skills where you know the
Growth Company is doing some good work
here but we need to spread that and do
more
um and then I think you know there are
areas where there is some genuine
challenge you know and some of the
things
um are quite difficult to achieve so
obviously we're hoping to do something
around business rates but as we've just
been discussing you know uh we have some
you know Financial constraints so we
have to be
um realistic about that so
um I hope that just
um what the report does is is show you
know what has been done but also
um in in a in a fairly open way where
we've still got to keep keep at this and
I think you know it's a cliche to say
it's a a marathon not a Sprint but this
is absolutely the case with this work it
does require sustained effort but please
be assured that um we're all working
very hard on that
thank you I mean so clearly
um you know I'm pleased that you've
you've got this report to us
um
I I think that
um a lot of work has been done and
achieved
um but I think there's a lot to be done
an awful lot to be done and
and I think you know how we're going to
meet our commitment
um across greater Manchester will will
be difficult
um but I think we you know we we do have
to crack on with a lot of this this work
um
questions
yeah counselor
uh yeah thank you for this I know
there's obviously a huge gap in what
we're doing what we should be doing and
I appreciate that the resource isn't
there and that is just heartbreaking the
resources there really
um but I do wonder whether you know more
things like around comms could be
explored for example
um I'm disappointed that the panel for
climate change is no longer planned but
I I'm aware other counters that have
like independent committees which
include not only businesses but also
schools colleges care workers
Community groups that kind of thing
because I do think that power comes from
the people as well and that we need to
be listening to Residents far more and
using their Knowledge and Skills because
change has also happens at that level so
I know you know we shouldn't all think
about how we need to change ourselves
but be with more awareness and people
being on mobile to make the changes that
we need such as reducing car use I do
think there is some scope there for
doing stuff that doesn't cost too much
um the other thing that um I was going
to ask about was I know that you know
with the big developments are coming out
Carrington Trafford Waters there's
nothing much we can do about that now I
think that you know I just went to gmca
brief and that knowledge of the horse
has already bolted in place for everyone
in terms of reaching their 2028 new
build Net Zero housing Target for
example
but I just want some reassurance in view
of future developments that we will be
more proactive in ensuring that
we don't have these you know the
enormous emissions that these
developments are going to create
um the other thing I was going to
highlight was that there's not anything
really on adaptation in this report
um for example how are we going to
tackle things at the high temperatures
um that were reached this year
especially for people living in blocks
of flats I think they're they're really
suffer there and things like flooding as
well in the future
um so it's really difficult isn't it
there's so much that we could be doing I
also was gonna sorry it was about the
Trafford youth cabin as well I think
it's really important to get them
involved
um
yeah I think that was main yet because
I'm sure everybody else will say the
other stuff I was going to say yeah I
mean could I just add to that really I
think places for everyone is really
important in terms of uh how we build
new homes with zero carbon and across
greater Manchester that that could make
a huge difference if we could do that
and
um well clearly there seems to be a
drawback
in in relation to that because we
haven't got
um the the plans in place to enable us
to deliver on on that so I'd just like
you know an emphasis on on how to put
obviously
um Jewelers raised a lot of other things
as well
so I don't know if you want to
try and answer those questions certainly
for me and thank you councilor Oxford
for your comments and I agree with much
of what you've said there um I think
your Reflections on Communications are
are correct um that is somewhere that
has been undertaken by the climate
change commission um across Trafford
with other partners from the private
sector from the public sector and also
from the voluntary Community Faith
sector
um I think there is more to be done
there on traffic council's part I'm
pleased to be able to announce that we
have now updated a bespoke climate
change page on the website I've checked
this evening and it isn't on the front
page of the website which was a specific
request so we will get that amended and
but I hope that that just just give you
some faith that
um that we are committed to trying to
improve Communications and that works
ongoing irrespective uh what you've said
around the way that other organizations
are doing I think you're right your your
Reflections are correct there and there
was recently a fantastic um conference a
school's conference in Seoul West where
we saw
um huge numbers of young people leading
on this agenda and I think what I would
like to see is a much more uh a much
greater emphasis on coordinating all of
the work that's been done across various
different constituencies
um in the borough and across greater
Manchester and and the country more
widely
um I absolutely take a point on um being
more proactive in respect of future
developments and the commitment to
carbon reduction I think I'd be right in
saying that that will be
um drawn out in the local plan as it
progresses but I'll let um Adrian
comment on that further and I I agree
with your Reflections on adaptation I
think the interesting thing is that so
much of the work that's already been
undertaken has emphasized on preventing
heat loss from properties rightly so
um in terms of retrofitting and
improving insulation and so on and we
have undertaken studies at greater
Manchester wide level
um which have looked to identify
um residential units in Trafford that
could be retrofitted and they have found
billions of pounds worth of investment
that could be spent um but I agree with
you around um that specific issue of
what happens when temperatures get so
high and I think of people living in you
know those blocks of flats where
potentially they could be really in
quite some significant discomfort so a
Passover to um Adrian and suggested they
have anything there that they wanted
I thank you guys as well yes so just
briefly on play on the planning and new
developments um getting the right
planning policy in place is absolutely
fundamental to that so we um so places
for everyone
um is is now progressing it's at
examination everybody's um uh from the
local Authority side is really happy
with the way things have progressed
during the first week
um many more weeks of course still to go
of examination so
um but at least we're there it's making
progress and that will make a difference
um to decision making
um once it's adopted and then the local
plan will be able to amplify that as
well so I take Point not uh things that
we can use yet but
um the right policies are very much on
the way
um and I think I guess you would say
anything about adaptations
um mitigations
on adaptations as well I'll do that one
um so yeah adaptation is obviously
really vitally important
um in terms of the the amount of heat we
saw this summer and the amount of
flooding and and other other climax
streams that we're now suffering in more
and more frequency
um the climate introduction plan doesn't
specifically deal with that that's more
based on mitigation that doesn't mean we
don't need it because obviously clearly
we do
um we're working at the moment with
Greta Manchester on a on a kind of like
a regional approach to adaptation
Manchester's got a very good framework
for adaptations as do a few other of the
boroughs across the region as well so
I'm looking to basically piggyback off
some of the approaches on that there's
also the center for climate and health
security which have now developed a what
are the process of developing a tool
kick to support local authorities in
addressing of adaptation
um although it's specifically like kind
of focused on on health but that's
clearly where the common social impacts
are felt but we also need to consider of
course biodiversity in terms of
adaptation needs as well so um it's a
matter of something we do have the uh
the outside support for that it's just
probably generating sufficient internal
resources to kind of drive a good
adaptation strategy at integrating that
across all the services at that takes
some level of coordination that I think
we need to think about as far as when we
look at what resources we need to bring
to bear to this piece of work
um I'm pleased to say you Dimension
comms and that communication strategy
we have a Communications plan within the
council working with Martin Dylan in the
comms team I'm pleased to say that now
allocated a specific officer to work on
addressing uh climate crisis priority as
well as other priorities
um so it's it's good that we do have
more you know allocated resources into
this priority but yeah obviously always
more resources is welcome but difficult
to find in these difficult times
and yeah thank you for that just wanted
to add something that
um didn't say earlier I mean I think in
terms of resources obviously it's
absolutely crucial and absolutely such a
high priority to get those resources and
it's I just don't know how we do it I
mean it's just like possible tasks but
um I know that I was just I'm aware that
say Warrington Council for example have
just funded a solar farm which produces
all its own electricity and they've
raised the money using Community
municipal bonds I know that there needs
to be the results to kind of look at
other sources of funding but I think
it's time that we were kind of maybe a
bit Bolder or somehow we had those
resources that that could be dedicated
to
try and find ways of investment and
funding and that kind of stuff because
it's just so so important thank you
just on that chair I I completely agree
I mean the studies that have been
commissioned by the council have
identified tens of billions of pounds
worth of investment and I think you know
when you see those sort of headline
figures my main concern is that really
what will drive forward this is um a
change of government in Westminster and
a meaningful contribution from central
government to realize this agenda
um what I would say and I don't want to
be two-party political but if there are
residents in Nottingham and Sarah West
watching they can play a role in that in
the next coming uh general election but
if you had any further comments just
then please do so
uh Council Carter on that note
thank you and um if that was you being
non-political I'd love to see it when
you're at the barricades schedule um
I've actually got four so thank you for
the reports
quite a lot of food for thought and a
degree of
um concern I've got four questions do
you want them all in one go or night
time on one go
um so first of all forgive me about that
if I missed this if this was already
covered you talk in the document about
enhanced planning requirements are now
being put in place for example EV
charging points and cycle storage
are similar
planning requirements planning to be put
in place to ensure new builds have high
levels high scores on EPC
second question
um
talks in in the document again about
private rented sector enforcement of
minimum epcs is limited in the short
term now many of our residents who are
renting will be in a degree of both
housing and financial relative
insecurity and to think that they can't
be protected with enforcement of agreed
levels of epcs because of
it is limited in the short term could
could we understand a bit more about why
that's please
third one short question
um and I've seen around cities elsewhere
you know some of the positive changes
e-scooters can make and I think in my
generation in my lifetime it's probably
the biggest potential Game Changer in
terms of moving away from uh private
motor vehicles
um so
are there any plans for us to have them
legally
um I don't have them by the way
um and fourthly
um
kind of a bigger
I don't want to say existential but a
bigger question around there's some
quite alarming misses forecast against
where we've said we're going to be a
pretty pretty fundamental as you if you
stretch out into the 19th 2030s
um so
and I haven't seen anything in here that
says but in a couple of years time we're
going to pull a rabbit out of a hat and
therefore change the trajectory of those
graphs so
realistically are we saying that they're
great targets and we're going to fail to
meet them
and are we calling that now
or
is there a a vision to
gain the resources that will meet these
tough targets because I can't see where
those new resources might be but what
the document appears to be saying is
the stuff you could do but we can't
because resources and if that's the case
I'll be declaring that we're going to
fail now
thank you
thank you and councilor Carter and in
terms of bpcs for new builds and no
great expert here but I'd be surprised
if we were developing new builds that
performed badly in terms of energy
performance I mean the average EPC for
residential unit in Trafford is D if I'm
correct and I'd be very surprised if
you're seeing new build developments
that are containing units within EPC at
level D
um however I'll defer to Adrian Ivy as
more insight on that and similarly with
the private sector enforcement I can't
pretend to be an expert in that regard
in terms of e-scooters I'm happy to pick
that up with tfjm and I've seen the
first they are being rolled out in city
of Salford as owners Monday I've seen
them all over the part of Salford that I
work in and I am pleased to confirm that
we have now
um granted planning permission for the
first of the B Network
um cycle hire
um docking stations to be installed so
we will see them all down in parts of
the north of the brother imminently
um in respect of the pull the rabbit out
of the Hat question and whether or not
the targets are setting is not to fail I
mean that I think that's his concerned
shared by everybody who's interested in
this agenda
um as I said before you know it's
exciting that trafford's commission
studies that indicates that there are
billions of pounds worth of retrofit an
investment that could be due to make a
meaningful difference around carbon
reduction
um
speak to the Trafford Park studies that
we've commissioned just reference the
retrofitting of residential units we've
also got work exploring the possibility
of the development of heat networks and
you know that does amount to tens of
billions of pounds worth of spend and I
don't think there's anybody here under
the illusion that traffic Council has
tens of billions of pounds hidden away
somewhere certainly Council of us is
shaking his head
um but if Adrian or Jazz Hut anything
they wanted to add to those questions
I'll I'm David to them
um yeah Ted thank you just just I
suppose on on the first one essentially
that that that's back to the planning
question so that's what we'll deliver
um uh some of that although we're also
seeing a steady ramping up of the
building regulations as well so so
hopefully that that kind of will
um uh certainly should um resolve itself
on the enforcement of of housing
absolutely we would love to do more in
this area I think the the difficulty is
at the moment we're finding some of the
really
um uh kind of immediate safety issues
like fire like
um you know poor elect uh poor
electrical safety
um you know
um really sort of kind of dreadful
um standard issues within private sector
housing are taking a lot of of time at
the moment from rather more than they
did at the past
um and equally
um the team's been very heavily engaged
on the homes for Ukraine program as well
so so we have had a bit of a uh
unfortunately bit of a temporary pause
but I'm pleased to say that we are now
putting Arrangements in place to try and
get an extra member of Staff into that
team so I'm hoping that will now give us
the capacity to kind of do some of these
thermal efficiency things because as you
say you know if we have a hard winter
and the present circumstances
matters of you know the thermal
efficiency of houses is going to become
really important so it is something
we're very keen to develop more
mentioned the ramping of the building
regs and I think a lot of people on the
table would be aware of the new home
standard of course which is
um kind of raised the uplift for now for
the 2022
um new bills need to be around about 30
um 34 better than they were at the um
from from previous building rigs which
is a which is a good Improvement which
is actually
higher to some degree than the places
for everyone was asking for
um and also by 2025 I've been looking
for them to be 80 better than the
previous building rigs which kind of
raises them all the way up towards the
EPC level a so building regs is already
doing that for us the question is do we
ask for it to be done quicker so you
know can we bring that forward by a year
so that that's one of the questions that
we we need to be looking at within our
planning system is what is their
evidence to demonstrate that to the to
the inspector that that's a reasonable
um request
I think um thank you Aging for answering
the the private sector enforcement
aspect to it um I think it's worth
pointing out of course you know like
um health issues within um damp houses
are often caused by poor Energy
Efficiency there anyway so a number of
the the issues around kind of EPC levels
can actually be be met by looking at
health and safety within these buildings
so it's not that big completely ignoring
them but as edger was saying the
priorities is has been kind of like high
level risks
um on the scale of the challenge
absolutely it's it it it is massive but
the target is set there based on the
science
not on the resources now normally when
you if you set a target for an
organization normally have an action
plan that shows how you're going to
deliver on that Target that looks for
the resources that is going to deliver
on that Target this is a different
situation this is a cliff Edge that if
we don't stop running within a few
meters we're going to go over the edge
it's no good saying we can stop in 10
meters time that's how much resource
we've got is too late so we've set a
Target based on what the science is
telling users need to do and what we now
need to do is fill in the background for
that and we're not alone in this of
course this needs to be done nationally
so there's a lot of national policy
which needs to be there to brought to
bed to support us there is a mismatch
between our local Target of 2038 and the
budget we've set the Carbon reduction
budget for that and the national Target
of 2050 which means National policy
might lag behind the speed of which we
want to see change but hopefully we'll
see National policy realize that
you know the the uh the budgets that
have been set in terms of carbon and
maybe not at the level of
um reduction that's actually necessary
and we might see as more and more
information comes forward about the
speed of change we're seeing in the
climate that we might see that that
reduction nationally needs to needs to
come a lot quicker with that that can
buy into a line by their own and work
there but there is no yeah there's no
unfortunately rabbit in the Hat
um and this this is what we need to try
and work with our partners and across
the region to see what can we use now to
make the biggest difference we possibly
can
okay
uh thank you chair uh the first question
is really a request for some
clarification or further detail that the
dashboard is very good at the high level
of showing uh where we're up to in terms
of success and where we're struggling I
wonder if it's possible to see the Excel
or the ganty off that sits behind that
to see the individual timelines for each
of the projects it'd be really
interested in seeing that I've scanned
through the rest of the report to see if
it's down there but I don't think it is
not expecting to produce it now but we
can have it as part of us a further
report or
um maybe emailed after this or pointed
in the direction whereas that'll be
fantastic
um
and the second point is ready to reflect
on the the soft power that the council
has in all areas of planet and we've
done an awful lot of work with disabled
accessibility on exercise in the soft
power of the council in the sense that
particularly big developers work with
traffic on a daily basis ask them to do
something if they're if they require if
they know it's required and it's there's
not a great cost impact they will do it
um and we've seen that um quite
extensively since we've started having
those conversations early with doing
with developers on disabled
accessibility and I wonder if this does
the opportunity to have similar
conversations in this area with
developers I appreciate the limitations
of building regulations I appreciate we
in terms of the um
uh the governance framework or waiting
for places for uh for everyone and the
local plan what does the whole area the
soft power we help in dealing with
developers on a on a daily basis just
wanted any comments on that from the uh
from the um the place soon thank you
things come from Stanley for your
questions and comments and we absolutely
we can get that detail for you in the
clarification that you requested
um at a later date when try to Wing an
answer for you right now
um in respective you sort of comments on
soft power I think you're right
um and I think
what I would like to see is do more of
is um broadcasting and championing the
good work that's already being done
um you know
we have a huge amount of Goodwill out
there and I don't think that we
celebrate and some of the stuff that's
been undertaken to Dayton off and
demonstrate that there's so many
different levels people are
um doing good work
um I would encourage members if they've
not been to go and look at some of the
stuff that we're doing in Greater
Manchester we've got the renew facility
in Trafford Park which is about uh
upcycling used goods and trying to keep
uh further life in them Council on
Oxford councilor accident I made a visit
to the um
waste resource extraction site in
Charleston within Shore the other day
which is where all of the recycling
materials of course greater Manchester
have processed ready for recycling and
in respect to paper that all gets sent
to Trafford park for processing
councilor so there's a huge amount
that's already been undertaken that I
think we just don't talk about and I
think that applies as well to other
partners in the private sector one of
the things that I'd be interested in is
maybe trying to see greater
participation from the private sector in
the climate change commission
um as at the moment we only have I think
two partners in the private sector sat
around the table and really I think
there could be more meaningful
engagement and I don't think that's
because of a lack of willingness
necessarily I think it's just it's not
as coordinated as it could be at present
and so I hope that's sort of reflects
some of your questions and comments yeah
and I think you'll you will find with
developers you're pushing an Open Door
because they want to do it they want to
do it
if you ask them they'll do it I think
okay thank you
yes um thank you
um I've got various points um
I think we just want to start mentioning
we've heard about places for everyone
there's a myth of places for everyone is
going to fix a lot of this there are
places for everyone who's not going to
give us zero carbon homes I'm afraid
that's that's not in places for everyone
we have to remember the place for
everyone set out with a principle of
prioritizing economic growth over
protecting our climate so the idea that
we're relying on this to fix this
problem and it's actually you know part
of the problem remember places for
everyone is asking us to double our
airport used over the next 20 years and
so we need to you know I I understand
the point made in the paper is a certain
um of the things we're trying to do like
the local Planet are stuck in the queue
behind places for everyone and I
realized that there are some
improvements in places for everyone but
in principle it is not prioritizing
protecting our climate and and that's
not what it's about
um of course it's being used as an
excuse and an explanation for building a
new road across Carrington Mass when we
know that building New Roads is exactly
what we don't need to do and what's
actually going to increase these figures
rather than reduce using them
um
so there's a few things I wanted to
mention in the report page 13 it talks
about how Council reports now include
specific considerations of carbon
reduction during this factored into
decision-making process and this is as a
result of uh green party suggestion some
years back but as I highlighted I think
the last time we met here and at
numerous meetings since this has been
brought in or if repeatedly highlights
the good elements and it doesn't
actually mention the bad elements at all
so if this is going to be used as part
of our decision making it needs to be an
act of actually an objective statement
or we can change it into where is the
green washing here what what are the
good things that mentioned the bad
things but if it protect if it purports
to be an objective statement as to what
the carbon impacts are of a report then
it needs to be that so we really need to
improve how that is working
um in terms of third-party dependence I
take Adrian's point there are various
things we're depending on happening you
know with um greater Manchester or other
places and I did actually go through the
report uh and the list of of items that
are at risk or or
um delayed and actually there's very few
there actually the the great majority of
these are things in Trafford council's
control
um and um and I take the point that we
have resource issues and which leads me
to ask actually I wonder how much of a
comes person we are getting on this
because I hear there's a bit of a commas
person share between this and some other
priorities and wondering how much of a
Commerce person that is and if that is
all the spare resource we had for
tackling climate is a little bit of a
comms person the best way of spending it
rather than saying some of the planning
departments or or elsewhere and I will
stop in a minute
can I just say the website still talks
about the citizens assembly again just
uncomes I've highlighted this uh several
times so not only would a resident
looking at our website think we're going
to have a citizen assembly they would
actually think we've already had it
because the data in there is March 2022
and it's a small point but
um again it's about being being straight
with people isn't it
um and just to re-emphasize I guess what
Jazz was saying about the science-based
targets and that winning slowly on this
is actually losing this isn't like other
you know targets where if we don't meet
it we'll meet at the following year and
it'll be a little bit worse or a little
bit worse it's just not like that this
is a win or lose and at the moment we're
losing and the science-based target is
not the year the year 2038 is not the
science-based target the science-based
target is the amount of carbon and
that's why on those graphs on about
Paige
uh 19 and 20 those precipitous drops
that we need to see they are the key
it's not where the it's not where it
ends it's not where it gets to zero that
matters it's a precipitous drop at the
start that matters and we have already
missed most of that so just as I say
reiterate that winning slowly is
impossible on this it's either winning
really quickly or or losing thanks
thank you um councilor Coggins for your
Reflections on the report I've respond
to the specifics that you've raised
there the ones that I can
um I agree with what you say about um
the carbon impact section of uh Council
reports and I had one put forward to me
about the a56 the other day and when I
checked it it was all talking about how
great it would be to improve active
travel without acknowledging that
necessarily when you do infrastructure
programs that is going to be a negative
carbon impact so I I take that on board
that report was pulled I think there's a
um you know I think the last time we
discussed this I said that it's going to
take some time to fine-tune
um and I think the reason it's slow is
because there is going to be a question
of trying to upskill quite a a wide
range of council offices but um I hope
we will get the I don't want to just
pile more and more work onto the
principal offices uh desk you see but we
will get there and I'll defer to um
Adrian and jazz on the how much of a
comms person that will get and I just
checked the climate change page on the
website I can't see reference to the
citizens assembly and I'm wondering if
maybe there's more than one page so um
I'll pick that up with you separately
outside the meeting that's the way yeah
thank you very much
I think yeah we'll we'll try and clarify
the the the the the the percent you know
the hours per week or what whatever
there's the right measure for the the
comms person
[Music]
of course
in the council and it took about three
years before we managed to get
um departments to realize what those
implications need to be looked at and to
treat them in a similar way as we look
at legal and financial implications
where a report doesn't go forward to the
executive without those things being
looked at properly and not just but
written by the officer in uh write the
report but also looked at by people who
can check that they've actually covered
them correctly because you wouldn't let
a report go through about legal with
someone's coming up there who wasn't
legally qualified to give you that so um
but with that there was again it's down
to resources how many people do we have
that qualify to look at doing that so at
the moment is a matter of really looking
at the big hit the big questions on it
now I've got a list obviously the of the
significant decisions they're going
through to Executive now over the next
few months and working with the
directors across the council I'll look
to try and support them and ensuring
that those implications are correctly
um you know comprehensively described
positive and negative as you as you
suggests and working with uh Council
Williams on that as well
thank you chair on this report I
realized there's a point mentioned we
used to have a Restless panel for
climate change and now there was an
event held down in November 2012 which
is this month it is not now proposed for
future discussion and also say we are
now devote efforts to other activities I
want to understand the rationale behind
it and I also want to understand what
are other activities has been scheduled
this is my first question secondly uh
also on the page
page five I think the session about
homes workplaces and the buildings it is
said kangso has now installed a range of
low carbon energy improvements including
heat pumps solar panels Etc across
public building risks across public
buildings I just want to clarify what
other what are the buildings included
such such as schools offices hospitals
Council houses what are they and do we
have other plans about this program
because I think one hand you can save
some energy but on the other hand you
possibly can generate some energy some
cash flow some cash flow based on the uh
low carbon energy systems such as panel
solar panel and batteries you can then
start trade with the grid that can
certainly help in current situation and
also I've heard many schools and
hospitals are very struggling to pay
their bill not only because of the cost
to be increased but also they just can't
have any capacity to do any Improvement
in terms of efficiency Etc so if we can
turn this this challenge into maybe a
uh cash generation probably not only
solve this issue but also help in the
long term yeah that's my two questions
thank you
thank you um Council energy for your
questions
um in respect to the citizens assembly
this has actually been addressed at a
meeting of four Council question raised
by the greens um I'm happy to sort of
repeat the um explanation here so um we
did commit to a Citizens assembly um
years ago after first forming an
Administration
um that work was essentially interfered
with by the covid-19 pandemic and the
lockdowns
um now when we picked it back up we were
receiving quotes of as much as a hundred
thousand pounds if not more to um
essentially just hold the event itself
and I think really if you want citizens
assemblies to be meaningful you do need
to properly resource them and trying to
do them on a shoestring budget they just
don't work
um and to be thanked my perspective was
that given
um such tight Financial constraints on
the council and referred to encounter
the law so it's really quite how Bleak
the picture is I felt that a hundred
thousand pounds or you know figures in
that amount could be used far more
effectively to actually progress the
work that we've already identified as
being required
um
irrespective your question about
um works that have been undertaken on
public sector buildings that's being
coordinated by the public sector
decarbonization scheme which is um a
scheme by national government being
rolled out in various phases you may see
um as you're looking around the board
that
facilities such as schools are now
starting to install solar panels and
heat pumps
um so that's essentially what you'll see
with that um happy to send you more
information about it if you so wish I'll
do so directly outside of the meeting
thank you
foreign no other questions
that's not a question I just wanted to I
just would like to request an update on
the com strategy or some more
information on it and another further
meetings
and and see if we can I think we already
said we've got a comms plan which
identifying what what we're going to try
and do over the next
um six to 12 months with it and there's
also a greater Manchester communication
strategy which has been developed as
well and that will be working with all
the authorities including ourselves so
um what I'd like to do is combine the
two together and give you a good picture
of what we're doing across the region as
well as locally
terms
the bank committee very interested in
that issue of disabled access to so you
build
um so I don't think you actually answer
these questions is it what's good I
presume there is a kickback from from
developers around trying to make
properties more
um
energy efficient
I think we call it a sea house or
something is up as a word for it
um
what's a feeling in the building
industry if you like around that
yeah I think I mean there is
um
there's there's been interest for for a
while
um I think we will find uh actually the
current cost of living crisis will will
will ramp up that interest but I think
to be honest the thing that it makes the
biggest difference are is the changes in
the building regulations because one of
the I suppose one of the most
developments are you know done
undertaken by the private sector that
they they want to be competitive in
terms of uh the product that they
provide
um and therefore
they're always anxious that you know
it's a Level Playing Field so in other
words that you know if you're buying a a
you know 100 square meter property
it's going to be a competitive price
from one developer to to the next
um and that's why I think this is this
is where you know things like the
building regulations or a universal
planning policy are really effective
because everybody knows where they stand
everybody knows what they've got to do
and they all do it to the same standard
um they can sometimes be a reluctance
not always
um to to sort of deviate from that but
but it's a very fair question and it's
worth it's always worth us pushing that
point and I think that's I took that to
what councilor Stanley was saying that
you know let's break the question let's
ask it no harm in doing that
um and as I say I think there will be
people who will be more interested in
this topic possibly not because of
climate change
um possibly because of cost of living
but nevertheless it will have the same
effect it will still be make more more
efficient um properties as a consequence
so certainly worth exploring further you
think it's probably developers are
developing a site you know
we do the outcomes tell her a few weeks
ago and someone did say to me you know
we so much need our housing you know
places for everyone
um
once it's into the housing rates there's
no argument it's uh that's gonna happen
just some cancer I just wanted to but is
the household waste recycling and I
would have thought behind them than that
I don't know why why is that because
it's an issue with we consumer document
pack page 19. yeah
Secret City recycling's gone up in the
bottom but it doesn't seem yeah
so the content household base which is
not consent recycling that's the amount
that hasn't been recycled so it's going
through energy energy composed or
smothering I was stressed out I don't
think any of it landfilled to be
honestly
and so that so that's proportion that
isn't suicidal and the other side of it
these are two and a bit we could
probably refer to tell you easier to add
up for the central household that has
been resolved with a compost and is 58.8
of the loss account right I suppose if
they will presented in both the
percentages for both times
but at the moment that's how they
describe does that is yeah is that a
huge issue is that going to work is that
going to affect our account on footprint
for a while because it is yes it does
movement because the more waste that's
produced the more you've got to
transport the starters yeah the more
resources you've got to do to process it
so
um that it does have a nominating
significant effects on UB the emissions
we include actually the the household
waste within the council's own
operational emissions where we have a
strong influence over how much waste is
recycled and composted so we actually
record that within our own kpi for the
councils like operations although it's a
it's a it's an insurance scope not a
direct impact and um and we can see and
there's work going on with the equality
to improve recycling within uh Flats to
maximize the Trudeau bin
um
and also to reduce the amount of waste
that's going into the residual pin
because that costs a lot of money yeah
so get more voice committed through
recycling bin and more waste going into
more paperwork to do in the blue bins as
well and in in conjunction with that we
also we looked looked to see Food For
Thought campaigns to try and help
residents to reuse scraps wherever
possible so they don't get anything and
also of course it's safe to household
money as well so there is improvements
going forward that'll reduce that annual
affect our performance
yeah
thank you
okay okay
yeah just on that item that was welcome
here as well I can say Obviously just
quicker than that one given the time uh
yesterday if the information I've seen
over at recent times yes the recycling
rate is going up in that sense your
overall uh obviously during the pandemic
council's Cross Country Recycling was
hit badly for a variety of reasons so
obviously now we're coming back up
there's still there was a tremendous
amount of work to be done and as the
officer was commenting there obviously
uh both locally and at GM and others
were actually trying to get as much uh
campaigns that we as we can do and there
are the highlighted ones in the flats
and so forth which is important because
Flats isn't everywhere there isn't as
much recycling done as there isn't in
houses so I think it's a certainly a
very important area that we actually do
that and there's a whole host of
campaigns that you've heard about
recently sold report from Trafford
member from traffic members Amy uh talks
about the gray Bean campaign that we've
done to try and make sure that we get as
much use of gray business that the
appropriate size to those households
that should actually have the normal
bins so there's that sort of work going
on but we have worked in other campaigns
constantly as well it's ideas actually
we can get up it and of course uh we
were expecting the uh National wasting
recycling strategy but like a lot of
things uh they've been delayed from
government in that sense that and we're
not quite clear when that'll be fully
coming through and we'll be working
through that so there's a lot worse
there's some good things happening I
would also reiterate of course uh it
says as well that there's almost never
Little Ghost to landfill at all there's
a very switching amount of personal
point one percent that can't be either
put through the heat exchange system to
generate energy or indeed but nothing
does go to landfill in that sense of it
across the legion just hope that's
helpful
foreign
data lab it gives a very clear outline
that will show all the numbers you were
looking at and you see but um it's very
clear that recycling is not going up
it's going down unless there is new data
that isn't on this this goes to 2021
um and the amount of waste not being
recycled is going up and I guess the
other point to always remember is that
recycling isn't a good thing we're not
aiming for more recycling we're aiming
to reduce that waste not recycled and
but the idea is that we get to very very
little recycling so it's it's always a
danger of thinking that recycling is a
good thing rather than the least worst
thing
um so we're talking about carbon carbon
emissions here and we want to get to a
neutral position so our missions
generally
um are we aware we're obviously aware of
that figures how does that feed into
that to
this work if you like
I'm not quite sure yeah
there's emissions that are not just
Carver isn't it okay so yeah
um there's absolutely question so
there's a range of um greenhouse gas
emissions which CO2 carbon dioxide is
the the kind of significant one um but
there's also others like methane
um those are cfcfcs
um NO2 in different situations can
create as well
um the
um as I was the the up the primary
emissions that that produce from from
um
uh transport it'd be calculated in terms
of carbon dioxide equip equivalent so we
we can calculate using the conversion
factors provided by the government of
how much for example how much diesel
vehicles produce uh from the council and
they are and we can get result in carbon
dioxide equivalents from that which
covers basically the greenhouse gas in
carbon dioxide equivalents in that so it
kind of reflects a wider range of
emissions and the um the base data the
government data for the borough is also
based on
carbon dioxide equivalence as well you
can go down and look in particularly
different types of greenhouse gas
emissions if you just want to report on
those particular ones but the over
overarching carbon dioxide equivalents
one does capture a wide range of
greenhouse gas emissions
thank you
love him counselor was just clarifying
doesn't mean that work hasn't been
undertaken in respect of other emissions
so the your note you'll be aware about
the Clean Air plan uh being coordinated
by uh the combined Authority in respect
to NO2 emissions so there are other
projects addressing
um other permission levels as well thank
you
okay then no other questions can I can I
thank you for coming along
and uh presenting this to us this update
to us
um it's much appreciated and answering
the questions that have been raised I do
feel that
um you know we need regular updates with
regard to the progress that it it is
being made
um and you know I think I think this
subject can sometimes be very depressing
because you're not you know you're not
clear I mean I'm not an expert and I've
never you know claimed to be an expert
but what I do know is that we need to
act
um as a council as a government and as a
world really to to ensure that we we do
the necessary work out to you know
ensure that our planet remains you know
livable
um for for our future generations and
and that's what drives me even though I
don't know much about it and I've been
told that I think tonight uh you know no
uncertain terms but
um that doesn't stop me from feeling
that we all together have to do
something uh about this and we have to
do it quickly really
um unfortunately you know we we you know
there's all sorts of things that come
crashing in whilst we we we're trying to
do this this work and you know things
like the uh climate crisis and pandemics
don't help these things
um but I think
in in terms of being a counselor you
know it is important that we you know do
take leads on on these issues and uh
that we do our best to to to improve
things so that's all that I would say on
that but
um yeah that thank you very much Darren
just to say you know this is my second
scrutiny committee on the charts always
more than happy to come back and speak
to scrutiny certainly the committee
feels um far more robust than when I was
on it and that might be of other poor
reflection on me or a very ringing and a
glowing endorsement of the work that
everybody around the table is doing so
no thank you very much um for the invite
the signature well thank you all the
three of you thank you
yeah
I was just going to say well when you
say you want regular updates
is it just attendance at the meeting or
would you like to receive like regular
emails with the program I mean I think
obviously you've got a template
um template for
you know looking at what has been done
and what is needed to be done it is
updating that really uh in in terms of
the things that haven't been achieved at
this point in time but you know what we
would like to see is that Improvement as
we go through all of those
more difficult issue should I say that
that's fine so we can um include
scrutiny committee members in the
um routine climate change commission
updates that are circulated if you want
and um if you want any further
commentary or dialogue then please just
approach me that's absolutely fine thank
you that would be good yeah so thank you
for that
um
no we'll now move on to
item seven places uh placing green
spaces into fields in trust and we do
have
um
we do have a report
and answers to some of the questions
that was asked previously
um
and I'll ask Steve are you going to just
introduce a paper yes thank you chats uh
obviously quite a brief paper yeah in
that sense and I think there was just a
couple of points out hanging about from
last time they're both on there so I
think try and combine them together from
my own perspective obviously it's a
there's some 156 Park well 156 parks and
green spaces in there and obviously it
would take us several years to actually
do this and with high grade officers to
actually uh to achieve this so I think
uh although there's actually less number
of official Parks you want to call it
that I don't think I personally would
like to start saying uh why one one park
or green space is less valid than
another in that sense it's I think
they're all equally value I think
they're all over a tremendous respected
by the community and I think I wouldn't
like to start saying that but we should
have it on one and not the other and so
forth so it can get it could get quite
complicated and quite messy we start
looking at that I think the other thing
that stands out for me quite a lot but
it'll take up to six years to do it says
something like that and it's actually
the time that officers would actually
stand doing it and that and the work
they wouldn't get done during that time
as well I think what's important is that
we have proper protection for parks and
that was outlined at the scrutiny
committee last time chair as you will
remember we set up number options and I
think uh so I think obviously I'd be
quite happy to work with scrutin
actually mate look at those uh options
around there and actually enhancing the
protection around other ways of doing it
and so forth there are in many ways so
actually easiest to do and we do them
without this huge amount of resource
several years doing it I think my big
fear is actually that the work that
won't get done given the uh resources
that we've got in terms of officers
availability and so forth I think at the
moment of time uh but we quite often can
struggle to get uh someone done some
things done as quickly as I would like
them others would like them but that's
the way things actually are and the
current climate so it was to say that
we'd have equivalent of losing six out
six years potentially of other types of
work and what would lose I think that
would be a loss that I would not like to
see and that's into it I think these
parks and green space are there
important so I think what's going to
matter to me predominantly is going to
be working this house to actually ensure
that everyone is happy about the types
of protection we can put on within the
resources that we've got already and
indeed within laws that are being passed
already across and protections in place
that not just fields and Trust because
whilst we are using I think that they
have been using special few sites as
with this detailed in the last committee
but I think that really we need to look
at something that's actually can be put
across all parks and I think the
proposals we've discussed last time will
actually do that quite adequately I
think it gives us capacity to actually
see what we can actually do with data
Parks like with fields and trust but
predominantly I think that I I could not
justify uh that all that taking that
time out from officers and the amount of
work that would actually potentially
lose for something that we can do
in-house and I think we can do it
protected and others come from
predominantly from where another local
Authority has done it but they're not in
the same position as we are that they've
got a lot less space than what we've got
here in that terms of it uh a certain
don't call it over provision I think we
might have more of it in that sense of
it but I think I'm obviously protected
with what we have about but I don't
think we necessarily need to go to the
same ranks like they've done enough
areas which also seen uh someone's other
authorities had other reasons for
potentially doing it as well which
certainly do not apply in this Authority
in that sense of do you think most of
allergies around the country so I think
I'm quite happy to actually uh well
protection about Abby they love to
actually say
to actually take that amount of time out
and resources away from that was at the
moment of Adrian has anything to add to
that
no I don't think so uh uh chair um I'm
obviously happy to take any any
questions
pretty straightforward it does answer
the questions there will be different
views I suspect but yeah councilor
Coggins briefly thank you to Adrian and
the team Francine these questions and um
that came from a green party proposal
um I.E I see the point that this would
take six years to do all this and I
don't necessarily see cancer adshead's
point that either we do six years worth
of this and nothing else or we just do
William Rowe turn moss and Crossfield
and if that is about saying some green
spaces are more important than the
others then obviously labor
Administration have decided that these
three are more important than say cow
field with their building on in
alteringham or say New Street Green
which is under threat being built on so
that decision if if you're choosing to
to make this about saying which green
spaces are more important than others
and then that is the decision that the
labor Administration have made and as I
say the cow field is owned by the
council to just to clarify that and
thank you for the answers yeah yeah but
I I don't think that that's correct I
think
um the the council has
previously and is doing today uh when
they feel that there is a need to put a
field in trust
um but particularly those times that
where they have been under threat land
has been under threat and that they've
considered to strengthen the
um you know
they uh this
you know for people
who want to utilize that for a different
thing that we can put more strength
around uh that that can't happen and I
think that's what the labor
Administration has has done quite
frankly the labor Administration is
building on the cow field we just need
that as a that just needs to be accepted
we can't just say labor Administration
is protecting all their green spaces
from being built on the cow field is a
park in altering hammers Recreation
ground the labor Administration owns it
and is building on it it just just need
that it should be accepted really okay
where we have introduced fields in trust
I think that that particularly the fee
sites happened we talked about last time
particularly uh that because they're
special one-off sites that don't fall
into the normal the types of parks that
we have satisfied with particularly
chose those as against other forms of
protection normal Parks nor green spaces
haven't got those sort of alternative
uses so I think that's why we're
suggesting the course of action that we
have proposed so I think I want what I
said I wouldn't like to treat the those
156 spaces and start dividing them up
the other three sites are one-off sites
and indeed there may be one-off sites
that come up in the future and and
indeed there may be such useful sites
that we want to put fields and Trust in
in the future I'm certainly not doing
that at all but what we're saying here
is that as a general rule for most of
their parks and green spaces that have
exist as parks and green spaces the
existing protections will give us
protection to do that but also uh Devas
a lot of
things that would have to go through
hoops and so forth to skip through okay
trying to think about wording uh if we
wanted to mention that so uh I'm quite
sure if there was any proposals like
that but given those protections and the
scrutiny role here that would be very
physically looked at I personally want
to see them built on myself and I'm sure
that I'd sit here before you uh if that
was the case and accidentally would not
be big enough to here I can assure you
on that one but those three sites are
entirely different so uh and we can't
compare those thank you
all right yes chill
um when this initially came on the
agenda I really wanted to understand why
Liverpool Council had felt the need to
do this and I'm still not sure I know
that
um I think that was kind of I was a bit
frustrated with with not really
understanding that I understand that
they're a different situation than us
and I just wanted I suppose we've got
the reassurance that you know that our
Green Space is will be protected by the
council but I still feel like there's a
little Gap in my knowledge about about
that which is
what I wanted to ask for previously but
thank you I that's fine yeah
okay
um
right
so no other questions on that
no
that's right
well we've got the answers
uh yes I was just gonna say
that's a committee are you going to um
put forward because the uh the original
motion was because you would put a
recommendation through to count on
um whether you feel that the putting on
the field of interest is feasible
um
I mean I I think we what what we're
saying is that we don't rule it out on
individual cases at any specific time
um if if the a view that uh it needs
extra protection uh most of our sites
and and parks are
um very well protected
um so that that would be my view that we
you know we we don't rule out
future
pieces of land going into the
field in Trust
and that has happened in the past and it
can happen in the future
but not to put it all in because if
you know to recommend put it all in it
will
um be
very expensive to do
um
yes it's office of time but it's office
a time that you know is needed in doing
something else so you'd have to employ
all the
or the staff to to to do the other work
so I couldn't
support that from the scrutiny
point of view so
so are we okay with that yeah
right
so
item eight is the committee work program
[Music]
and we have a report
I'll just bring up
so
are there any questions on
on these
and I know that
um
counselor Walsh
not at the moment well you you
may want to say a few words about
yes
yes yeah of course um task and finish
regarding events at Old Trafford
um
at the moment working out a survey for
residents to fill in
um
various members of the committee have
been um I've been taking part in that
and that isn't hasn't been released yet
Alex has it okay councilor Carter from
comms as it'll go out through PR either
Friday or Monday supported by councils
social media so by Monday yeah it'll
have been releasing media announced on
social media and then it's too
task and finish members to do to promote
that amplifier yeah yeah so the best
councilor cat said I hope all uh members
indeed on this committee and all members
of the council that he can promote could
promote that survey it'll be on the
council website for people to fill in
and quite simply want to know what
people think about their experience on
Match days
um there's lots of opportunities there
for people to give the views and then
we'll we'll go away and analyze that
data
um I think then that that is the plan to
analyze that data and then decide on a
way forward but we would be looking to
talk to uh to the police invite the
policing for discussion Manchester
United and indeed our own Services uh
within the council
um
so I think it's a very positive start
and uh and and lots of members have been
contributing to it so I think it's a a
good way forward a good way to start
thank you chair yeah okay thanks for
that
um
uh councilor win Stanley
uh thank you chair it's just a point on
the
um disability access thank you
transparent that I am
um
is that there was a I wasn't at the last
meeting I saw the minutes from my last
meeting there were three action points
the three recommendations from the for
the interim reports uh I had item two
and three were answered quite
comprehensively according to the minutes
I'm not conscious of seeing an answer to
item one which is the um very conscious
of the limits of building regulations
and pure planning regulations as it were
as but several conversations with our
own governance team and with outside
Consultants including direct access who
who are doing work within the council
now
is that there's a there's a huge scope
of using the public sector equality duty
to put not only the building not only on
the soft power the council has with
developers but while we wait for the uh
improved governance framework but also
to use to some other pieces of
legislation like the public sector
equality duty to force developers and
other applicants to take action on
disability access and I just can't just
have not I've not seen an answer so
yeah
we have that minister to receive an
answer
um well I can find out that if you if it
wasn't earth covered within the response
no one can take it back and ask for a
further response from the executive that
would be brilliant Adrian I'm sure
glance across Adrian while he was still
here but I'll send it as an email from
the committee that they asked for the
um information I said it's just an
answer it's it's quite clear what the
recommendation was there's access
specific questions and answers to that
specific question
thank you
and I think it's
um the the timeline of
um getting a
kind of response of the delivery of the
plans that are being drawn up at this
moment in time
which would enable the disability access
to be in that plan
um
and how long that might take I think
that's another part of it isn't it are
you sitting down again
I'm sorry Tara I wasn't
um I perhaps should have stayed though
my last item was the earth Hills and
Trust one so yeah it would be obviously
um the public sector equality Duty one
I'll liaise with Alex over over that and
if it would be helpful to see the
timelines for the uh places for everyone
and the local plan then I'm sure we can
certainly provide that as well so that
won't be a problem okay
thanks now you can go home
yeah no thank you thanks for that
and The Travelers
um which we we had a task and finish
group on that and there was uh we we did
all the executive did actually respond
to us uh by saying that the further
report would come in December or before
the end of the year
um that's my recollection
and so
I don't know when we'll can you chase
that up because obviously we're getting
close to the end of the year aren't we
uh that's a report a further report
that's going to the executive but it
will also come to this committee I'll I
can circulate the report via email but
yeah you could have it um yeah taken as
an item at the next meeting if you want
I mean that that would be fine if you
could circulate it to all the members to
report of the executive
and I'll attend the executive anyway so
I'd appreciate if it could be on the
agenda as well yeah yeah yeah definitely
okay counselor today
yeah thank you chair I think we all
expressed uh interest in the climate
change action plan can we add that
section into our future discussion maybe
the March session
next year
yeah I mean I think
I suppose it's when
a
meaningful update will be produced so
I'm not sure about
timetables but but that's something that
Alex you might ask you know when
they would produce I should have
probably asked it before
um before they went that
um when they will be updating yeah
like this it's got nothing updated
there's no point in it and they will be
providing those regular updates via
email now I don't know how often that
can
um councilor Coggins information
um the climate commission gets these
updates four times a year so every three
months
um obviously the conservative party and
liberal demo of cup party are welcome to
attend just as as the Green Party do
um but they're rarely there so if you
guys want to see what's happening you
can come to the meetings as a place for
each party there
members
yes so that would be useful yeah
yes Jill just about the Carrington
relief Road I'm just a feature around
the the problems around the costings and
also some more information when the
consultation is going to be and yeah uh
yes counselor I did raise that with um
Adrian yesterday when you sent me it was
just send it Dave before me sent the
email and uh he'll have that information
that he's
um was mentioned about the financials uh
into within two weeks so you'll get that
within that time what was the other
point that you just raised
um consultation for data the
consultation yeah
[Music]
excellent so is there anything else on
there
yes
forgive my ignorance and my poor memory
but on a a quick rough sample of two
none of neither of us know what hi map
stands for
you
oh
I've just Googled anything to do Health
in the Philippines I know it's highways
um improvements
uh something maintenance yeah yeah
um
using new services and
um utilizing new Services dealing with
potholes all of those kind of things I'm
I'm delighted to ask thank you chair
right is there anything else
no
um item nine
urgent business
no and exclusion resolution we don't
need because there's no other business
so that is the end of the meeting and
can I thank you for
your attention and your questions
which were really good I think tonight
uh and have a safe journey home